Today we're going to begin in depth
exploration of a topic we've already come
across a few times.
The duty of good faith.
We're going to start by discussing sent
tronics corporation versus Gen Acom
Corporation.
A case decided by the Supreme Court of
New Hampshire in 1989 the case concerned
a rather complicated transaction
for financial assets.
Spintronics agreed to sell and Jen Acom
agreed to purchase certain business
assets.
The parties agreed that the purchase
price of the assets would be pegged to the
assets value at closing
because of the price. Uh,
value couldn't be known at the
time that the contract was formed.
The parties agreed that disputes over
there the ultimate purchase price would be
referred to an accounting
firm for arbitration.
The parties also agreed that pending
finding final valuation of the assets,
Jen Acom would deposit a portion
of the purchase price into escrow.
The parties did indeed disagree about
the value of the assets at closing and so
began arbitration.
The arbitration process apparently
was taking longer than the parties
anticipated and while
arbitration was still ongoing,
Sin Tronics requested that Jen ECOM
released from escrow the portion of the
funds that were not in dispute.
Jen and calm refused to do so and send
tronic sued arguing that [inaudible] had
breached an implied
obligation of good faith.
Jen ECOM moved for summary Judgment,
which the trial court granted the New
Hampshire Supreme Court in an opinion by
then judge and now former Supreme Court
justice David Souter affirmed Sutor did
not deny that an obligation of good faith
existed rather his opinion focused on
what good faith requires.
Seutter outlined three categories of
cases in which good faith disputes might
arise,
cases dealing with standards of
conduct and contract formation.
That's the first category.
The second is cases concerning at-will
termination of employment contracts and
the third is limits on discretion
in contractual performance.
These three categories corresponds to
three different times of the contracts
existence. It's formation,
it's termination,
and what happens in between the good
faith requirement can always be seen as
limiting discretionary behavior.
Seutter saw that the limits on discretion
though differ depending on whether
we're talking about a contractor,
his discretion in forming or terminating
a contract or an exercising discretion
during the contract.
That is how to perform a contract when
there is some discretion granted one side
or the other under category one
concerning good faith in formation.
Good faith is tantamount to the
traditional duties of care to refrain for
misrepresentation and to
correct subsequently discovered
error in so far as any
representation is intended to induce
and his material to another party's
decision to enter into a contract
in justifiable reliance upon it.
Basically suitor is saying
that you have to be honest,
both explicitly and implicitly when
dealing at arm's length in negotiating the
possible formation of a contract
under category two concerning at-will
termination of a contract,
the good faith obligation
limits and employers power
to fire an at will employee
good faith is violated when employer
fires and that will employ quote out of
malice or bad faith in retaliation for
action taken or refused by the employee
in consonance with public policy
unquote combing through precedent.
The court determined that good faith in
the third category of cases into which
the instant dispute fell requires quote
and implied obligation of good faith to
observe reasonable limits in exercising
that discretion consistent with the
parties purpose or purposes
in contracting unquote.
The court further broke down the
analysis required for category three
discretionary performance cases
into four questions. First,
whether the contracting question
aloud or conferred upon the defendant,
a degree of discretion in performance
that was tantamount to a power to deprive
the plaintiff has of a substantial
proportion of the agreements value.
Second,
if it did,
whether the evidence suggested that
the parties intended to make a legally
enforceable contract. Third, if so,
whether the defendant exercise exercise
of discretion exceeded the limits of
reasonableness.
A question that required identifying
the purpose of the contract and forth,
whether the damage complained of resulted
from events beyond the control of
either party.
But the court didn't need to run through
each of these four questions because it
determined in,
uh,
the decision in answering the very
first question that the contract did,
it found did not confer discretion upon
Gen ECOM to deprive send tronics have a
substantial proportion
of the agreements value.
The court examined the contractual
provisions governing release of the funds
from escrow.
The escrow agreement provided that quote
in accordance with section 2.07 of the
purchase agreement.
The escrow agent shall hold the escrow
funds in its possession until instructed
in writing unquote by the parties lawyers
quote to distribute the same or same
portion thereof to send tronics or Jen
Acom as the case may be section 2.07 of
the purchase agreement and titled Final
Payment of purchase price stated quote,
final settlement and payment
of the purchase price shall
be made not later than
10 days after determination of the closing
value and computation of the purchase
price, whether by agreement of the
parties or decision of the arbitrator.
These provisions were in the court's
words, express and unequivocal.
They gave Jen and no discretion
to withhold payout for approved,
uh,
for approval beyond that time or to affect
the timing of the arbitration itself.
Because of this,
the court concluded the gender Khan was
not given discretion such that it could
deprive and tronics indefinitely of a
portion of the greed consideration for the
business assets previously transferred.
The court addressed discretion beyond
the timeline specified in the agreement.
What about before that timeline?
Does Jen ECOM have discretion to
release the funds before 10 days after
determination of closing value?
The court believed the text of the
agreement supported the claim that the
parties intended the escrow agent to
leave the fund intact until the point of
final payment,
if any,
that would be due to send tronics 10
days after the final price determination.
Good faith did not require Jen come to
do something in consistent with the terms
of the agreement and here I'm quoting
what send tronics claims to be Jenna comes
discretion over the timing of distribution
is in reality a power that each party
may exercise but only jointly with the
other two agree to remove some or all of
the escrowed funds from the ambit of
the otherwise mandatory payout provision
unquote.
The opinion further agreed with the trial
court that it wasn't the judges duty
to quote insert a provision in the
contract for partial payments were such
provision does not exist.
The court will not renegotiate
the contract between the
parties to obtain this
result. In determining how to
approach the good faith question.
Suitor discussed two scholars,
Summers and Burton,
and there are differing understandings
of the meaning of good faith.
Summers adheres to an excluder analysis.
He defines good faith as
anything that isn't bad faith.
He denied that certain words or phrases
have a general positive meaning of their
own,
but instead quote function to rule out
various things according to context
unquote.
One example he offered is the
word voluntary in criminal law.
Quoting a philosopher summers argued that
when we say someone acted voluntarily,
the word serves to exclude a heterogeneous
range of cases such as physical
compulsion, coercion by
by threats, accidents,
mistakes,
et cetera.
Voluntary itself didn't designate
a specific mental state.
Summers believes that
good faith is similar.
It functions as an excluder to rule out
a wide range of heterogeneous forms of
bad faith.
Such forms of bad faith include evading
the spirit of bargain and abusive of a
power to define specific terms.
Burton by contrast advocates
what he calls a recapture theory.
He explained that parties give up certain
opportunities at the time that they
contract.
He termed this the expected
cost of performance,
a party acted in bath,
bad faith burden,
argued quote precisely when discretion
is used to recapture opportunities for
gone,
uh,
upon contracting when the discretion
exercising party refuses to pay the
expected cost of performance for the
purposes of analyzing good faith and
discretion during contract
performance of this third category,
Seutter said that he found
summer's analysis more in
line with the New Hampshire
press precedent.
Nevertheless,
the four question test he set out reads,
especially with its emphasis
on con contracts, purpose,
somewhat like an implementation
of Burton's recapture theory.
In any case,
sooner explicitly attempted to analyze
the case in recapture terms and
determined that even by those terms,
Jenny comms actions wouldn't
constitute bad faith.
This was because first Gen McCombs
refusal to consent to distribution from
escrow.
Quote neither recaptures nor gains Jen
and calm anything in and of itself.
The refusal removes no issue from the
contingencies of arbitration and gives Jen
and Cobb no present or future rights to
the money it wishes to obtain unquote
more significantly.
The court emphasized that to Burton's
parties expected costs depend upon
objective analysis of the
party's expectation as they
may be inferred from the
express contract terms.
In light of the ordinary course of
business and customary practice,
the courts objective analysis found
that the parties expected the escrow to
remain intact during the arbitration.
The parties us quote never bargained
away the right of either of them to
condition any distribution on completing
the arbitration of any disputes.
Jen income by insisting arbitration be
completed before releasing escrow funds
then was not trying to recapture
a foregone opportunity.
I'm not as sure that Jen Acom had not
by default bargain away the right to
resist releasing escrow bounds,
not at risk would rational parties give
Jen and calm this power of insistence it
it gives Jen and calm bargaining power
to possibly get sent tronics to agree to
less than the arbitrator
would ultimately give.
Judge shooter seems to think
this bargaining power was
what sen tronic signed up
for. So Jen Acom wasn't using its
progression to get anything extra,
but a contrary ruling that was
explicitly a default might not have been
contracted around by many parties.
Then again,
this bargaining power might have also
affected the initial price sale price that
was offered knowing that there would be
a difficulty negotiating in its shadow.
More generally,
how should a court think about a use
of discretion that gives defendant very
little and costs,
uh,
the plaintiff Alot if
choosing x instead of, uh,
instead of y gains the defendant a penny,
but cost the plaintiff $100,
is that bad faith if it
gains the defendant $99,
but costs the plaintiff 100, is
that small inefficiency, bad faith?
If it gains the defendant $100,
but costs the plaintiff $100
and is just a transfer of, well,
can that ever be bad faith?
I'd be attracted to saying
that using discretion,
even discretion and refusing to modify
a contract should be bad faith if it
creates massive inefficiency.
Imagine though that Jen and [inaudible]
were found to have acted in bad faith
and performing the contract.
Is that a separate cause of action?
Well,
some jurisdictions do recognize a
separate cause of action for failure to
perform or enforce and in good faith,
but most do not.
Instead,
construing the failure to perform specific
contractual terms in good faith as a
breach of contract restatement.
Section two oh five says
that the appropriate remedies
in breach of good faith
cases can vary according to context.
Sin Tronics is a pretty packed case.
There's a lot to take away from it.
The primary takeaway,
the one most relevant to the dispute
between San Tronics and Jen accom was that
good faith and contractual performance
arises only in the context of the party's
exercise of discretion.
But beyond that,
we talked about suitors classification
of different good faith scenarios and
corresponding understandings of
what could good faith entails.
We also discussed too influential and
very different understandings of good
faith.
The excluder theory espoused by summers
and the expected cost or recapture
theory, uh, ex championed by Burton.
Think about which of these
you find more persuasive.